but first we go to Saudi Arabia where
arts 21 was allowed the rare privilege
of filming we visited a spectacular new
building designed by a German architect
it's already become something of a
landmark in Riyadh the new King Fahad
National Library the building is
officially due to open in November when
the design by eka Gabba
and his team won a competition in 2002
it became their paths into Saudi
Arabia's huge construction industry
we've had so many lovely Commission's
here and most of them we'd never have
had in Germany although traditionally a
strict conservative and isolated country
Saudi Arabia is beginning to open up and
modernize here in Riyadh's new king
abdullah financial district gare-bear is
building a modern Information Center a
butterfly garden and one of the main
stations on the kingdom's inaugural
underground line the RER Development
Authority is looking to gather
architects Dortmund for more and more
construction projects we find the way or
the the style of gear bar is pure clean
lines and it's belong to the local
architecture the library's facade
comprises an elegant network of sales
that serve both as sunshades and a nod
to Bedouin culture inside the rooms of
functional and airy the library is
covered but inside it's still very open
you have this wonderful view outside
behind us is the beautiful park which
may also help the plan you have a view
all around the city and yet the building
is protected this dialectic interplay
forms the core of my work so I enjoyed
my not a bite
/ FR alba wali is a young architect
looking for a good job and this is her
kind of architecture but she didn't
graduate from Riyadh's new women's
university the Saudi government sent her
to study in Germany but finding work is
tough in Saudi Arabia women are banned
from driving and living alone brothel
wants to get into a profession once only
open to men but still she must adhere to
Saudis trick laws that also apply in the
new national library is a Saudi woman I
think it's good that there's a
department where I can move freely
without the cloak without a veil it's
well-designed with glass and natural
daylight and still the women aren't seen
from outside I like that but
unfortunately there's still quite a lot
of artificial light here and it's a bit
more cramped than the open reading room
upstairs women will be allowed into the
main reading room once it's opened but
only under a veil the windows here are
transparent not frosted like in the
women only section what Rafa likes best
is that the old 1980s library has been
fully incorporated into the new one it
will be used to store books connected to
the new building by a series of foot
bridges but it's rare in Riyadh's
booming construction sector for old
buildings to be integrated into new
architecture it would be nice if people
built modern buildings but at the same
time kept the old architectural sole
there's very little traditional Arab
architecture left in the country here in
the old port city of Jeddah buildings
are still adorned with wooden shutters
that protect their occupants from the
glare of the Sun and the eyes of
strangers
in the works of gerber architects these
traditional latticework features and
constructions are given a modern twist
like another of their big projects in
Riyadh the Prince Salman signs Oasis the
facades of the exhibition pavilions are
made of glass fiber cement with
computer-generated patterns based on
traditional designs what I especially
like in Garib are architects designs is
the master BIA these pieces that are
very traditional here and then are
painted bold colors then they look
modern and traditional at the same time
beautiful the sphere will eventually
become a venue for 3d movers a minor
sensation in a country known for its ban
on cinema but for now the Prince Salman
signs oasis is still just a construction
site can Rafa imagine working here in
this male domain
actually I'd enjoy it
I'd like to work on something like this
but probably not in Saudi Arabia firstly
because I'd have to dress like this in
black and that's impractical for work
and secondly men aren't used to seeing
women in the workplace a woman on a
construction site is a bit problematic
in Saudi Arabia but if Rafa wants to
learn the construction side of things
she do well in Germany where that's
normal here is still things have a ways
to go I hope that someday it'll be
possible for women to work on a building
site in Saudi Arabia - we're gonna work
on it yes maybe we'll be the first Rafa
doesn't know yet whether she'll work for
gabbar Architects in Saudi Arabia or
Germany or elsewhere but the young Saudi
architect and her German colleague are
unanimous they've picked the best job in
the world
we descent every country has to develop
and I think architecture can play a
major role in that architecture
influences people subconsciously no one
notices it either in municipal rooms or
a building they form certain
sensitivities and that shapes the people
and it's gradually our country develops
exam of vitae intrical
you